The next optimization in view mode I want to talk about
is Quad Overdraw.
Now, Quad Overdraw is used to help determine areas
which are going to cause your GPU to go in to overdrive
trying to calculate triangles.
Now, the reason for this is that GPUs work on a 2
by 2 quad granularity, which
means that small thin triangles that
are smaller than 2 by 2 pixels result in extra work
for the GPU to have to do.
Quad Overdraws will show you which meshes could
be suffering from this issue and allow
you to make better, more informed choices about how
to approach that.
Now, the cool thing about Quad Overdraw
is that the easiest way to address this
is to simply add a level of detail
and then reduce the level of detail's geometry
so that you can still have mesh
that has a silhouette that is similar while being cheaper
to render.
One other thing to note about Quad Overdraw
is that if you're working on a VR project,
Quad Overdraw is particularly important to have
to pay attention to because, remember, VR is rendering not
everything just once but everything twice.
So any way that we can cut down
on the amount of work or overwork the GPU has to do
will be a big win for optimization overall.
As with all of our other view modes,
we want to try to keep the view in the ideal to moderate.
And again, the idea here is to look
for areas that have issues and not try and overoptimize
to make our entire scene completely blue or green,
destroying the artwork in a negative way.